because you have such a great television
show what do you love what are you
watching right now well I love always
love Judge Judy that's my goat skin oh
my god every day I I love it it feeds my
soul you all need to get together and do
something now that would be some tea but
that's our go to judge that's the one
judge I have to have on the show you
don't boy I didn't come to play I came
to slag I'm America's drag superstar
competitions on now the show is in what
I think it's 50th season something like
that something like we've been doing for
a long time and we're just so excited to
have a job no you know that that really
teaches you that to be grateful what do
you look for in good style you know it
depends on a person you have to
understand your own rhythm your own
frequency and that's what you dressed
you you can't just put you know
something it looks good on a runway
model on your body it has to work for
you when you go full-on love what is a
must-have for RuPaul it's all about the
attitude if I can't sell it if I can't
feel it it's meaningless
[Music]
you